okay now it's time that we handle some
Oscar business okay
every year the votes for the Academy
Awards are tabulated by the firm of
Price Waterhouse and Coopers here are
two of their accountants Murray Sugarman
and David Moskowitz
what's the problem okay these guys get
me my money
by all means necessary okay you won't be
able to take your eyes off these next
four presenters Penelope Cruz and Selma
Hayek
our first category is sound mixing where
the talented efforts of the production
and post-production sound mixing combine
artistry with technology to create
intimate portraits and vibrant sound
scapes which allow the audience to fully
experience the filmmakers vision and
here are the people who did an
outstanding job
in accomplishing that task
Tom Fleischmann and Peter leader for The
Aviator Randy Tom Geary ERISA and doc
came for the incredible Randi Tom Tom
Johnson Dany Sanz and William B Kaplan
for the Polar Express Scott Mullin Greg
Olaf Bob BEMER and still can't Amazon
for raising Kevin O'Connell Greg P
Russell Jeffrey J haboos and Joseph
Geisinger for spider-man 2
and the Oscar goes to
Scott melon bread and speed
this is the third Academy Award in sixth
nomination for Scott Malone and Bob
BEMER this is the first winning
nomination for Gregor law and Steve
can't amazing
Wow it's it's impossible to express how
lucky we were to work on a film about
the gentleman Ray Charles the
storytelling allowed us to use sound and
we were very lucky that Taylor Hackford
our director gave us our freedom and we
have to thank Stuart Benjamin are
produced we have to thank everybody at
Bristol Bay we have to thank Bill Brown
and Lisa Denis and Paul Hirsch our
picture editor and sound editorial of
Karen Baker Landers and pare Hallberg we
have to thank Oh Kurt Sobo our music
editor and please we'd like to thank our
sports staff Fred Peck and I'd like to
thank my crew Gary Thomasson Scott LaRue
and Aaron Zeller thank you
this next award is for sound editing the
sound editor takes all the usable
original auditory elements involved in a
film plus the new production tracks
which includes sound effects dialogue
and other sounds and delivers them to
the sound mixer sounds good to me
so here are the people who are nominated
this year for sound editing
Michael Silver's and Randy Tom for The
Incredibles
Randy Tom and Dennis Leonard for the
Polar Express
Paul MJ audison for spider-man T and the
Oscar goes to Michael Silver's and Randy
Tom for the increase in credible this is
the first Academy Award and third
nomination for Michael Silver's multiple
nominee Randy Tom takes home his second
Oscar thank you so much certain Academy
Awards like sound and visual effects and
editing or sometimes referred to as
technical Awards they are not technical
Awards they're given for artistic
decisions and sometimes we
sometimes we make them better than
others and I guess we made a couple of
good ones on this one thank you so much
Brad Bird and Skywalker sound
Lisa and Austin this is for you I'd like
to share this with my superheroes the
sound editing crew and Lois Rebecca Emma
Bonnie I love you thank you